今日じゃ最近体がボロボロ和社長です
でも全然元気なんだよ元気だの体がずっと最近体調が悪くてネット防止あげないんです
けど最近だとあじゃあマッハそして
新たな痛みが発見されましたハイあのちょっと今年3年増えたせいか何か楽しいんだ
けども大変みたいなことはすぐに続いてあの体の方が本格てに来ております肇社長でお
仕事頑張ってる皆さん
道具
無理詰めてくださいっていうあの僕みたいになる前になんとかして欲しいということは
の砦伝えたいです多分今月はずに雪はスペシャル痛みフェスティバルになっててまず
頭痛がずっと治らないというやつが起きてでまたが痛すぎてやないけたいですねすごい
たかったですが起きて今度はですね肌がボロボロになってきました
これ大丈夫かなんか見せたら黒
ウィンダーのちょっとグロいの苦手な方はお控えください腕なこのここの腕っていうの
かな
関節部分こことかあと膝裏とかいじ裏膝裏がなんかめちゃくちゃかよくてみます右は
そんなんだ
右がこんな感じですか良い音でボケそんな中アトピーとかないと思うんですけどここ
だけめっちゃかよくなって
こうなってますで右がいいんですか左がすごいんですよいきますよちょっとまず黒中古
そんなん異形
見えるかな音なく皮膚が狡猾ですねバリバリしてるんでここらへんとやまもうなんか
リカーズ社範囲がじゃない助けてっていう感じになっておりまして
まあ年からその痛みとは別でずっとかよかったんですよってなんか寝てるとにも強いに
聞いたらかえってたみたいなこと言っててもう無意識で
カイザーぐらい
bar もう今も書いてたあぶないあぶないで僕結構あの肌弱いんでカイザーズ数が
荒れるんですけどそれの最終形態というかあれが取れなくてずっと書き続けた今こんな
のになっちまいましたやばいこれた船はわかんないけどあとに残るかもしれないが
やばいですからねずっと書いて書いて書いて帰ってて日がたってあの今に至ったところ
を担いて血が出たり痛いですさわっ
見たいしオロナインとか塗っててもあんまりも効果がなくて北長野であんま好きじゃ
ないんですよ結構服とかまくってるんですけどここに吹く当たってるのがすごい嫌な
タイプの人間で何かそういう季節の変わり目ですが当たるようになったのとか疲れとか
なかったストレス寝不足そういうのはたぶん関係してくださっている私の読みでござい
ますねまぁ皮膚科に行ったら多分綺麗になるだろうという読みでちょっと今から
病院に行ってきますではグルーを混ぜて黒いだろこれよねんえやばいよ
いや
待ってお魚さんですかみたいになってるよあーこれ黙ってなんか白くなってかわよ
[音楽]
ん
ぬーん
みんなに基づく ana いっ
カレーが別にいいとしてさあみたいな本っても同市内からなやつケツしてると言いたい
です
よそしくあたっていたからこれで歩くのがめっちゃの数だって
よくだけそれを率はダメ思っセスっていきましょういいんじゃないしねぇ
ますけどねいってらっしゃい
[音楽]
入るあってて
9というわけで帰ってきましたもうすごかったです医者の人に見せた瞬間
うわぁこれ限りでしょ
って言ってたんで入っていっておりますめっちゃ薬もらってきためっちゃ来てもらって
きたってはやっぱり基本的に塗り薬ですね
塗り薬とべさらにその上の塗り薬ポスター痒み止めのあの痒み止め村んね上式に書くん
でもう薬で抑えるしかないということで桜よを持っていますよこれが最強の発作言っ
てりゃ治るそう
というはすごいなんですでシビア立ってるからすごいです痛い名前罰ないんですけど
痒いんどもめちゃくちゃ痛い我慢できないですも書いちゃうと気持ちいいからね
ずるいよねもうかけませんそれはというわけでお医者さんに行ってきてどうして僕の腕
がこうなってしまったのが原因8
聞いてきました
原因は
ん
乾燥肌ですそんなグレイス配布だけ原因は乾燥肌だったみたいですねあのユーテックの
通り僕肌弱いんで乾燥肌でこれ感想をしてる季節によく起こりやすいらしいですよね
本当するだけですねかアトピー性のほどもないんし原因がねその感想とかきついなもの
以外にもあの僕寒いとで弾い
とテック切るんですよ今も来てるんですけどあったかいやつね化学繊維んじゃねぇず
あんまり皮膚に良くないな作ってそういうので何か悪化の原因になっているのでは
みたいなこと言われますターゲットで
きれねーって寒いをマートンヒートテックみたらアーク線を止めて並べ方ないようにし
て保湿をしっかりするっていうのが珍しいですか良い来ていた院結構つらかった
これ塗ってると4日5日ぐらいで結構いてくるらしいので念が同じ飲んで悩んでる人い
たらとりあえず長袖で室れるのはまぁ良くなりませんで
ヨハンソレってことをキッツ
[音楽]
car
me
あっはぁ